>> CRIMINALS GETTING MORE BRAZEN
IN CHICAGO AFTER A POLICE
OFFICER IS GUNNED DOWN DURING A
ROUTINE TRAFFIC STOP.
29 YEAR OLD OFFICER ELLA FRENCH
WAS KILLED IN THE LINE OF DUTY
WHILE HER PARTNER REMAINS IN
CRITICAL CONDITION AFTER BEING
SHOT THREE TIMES.
SADLY THE CARNAGE DOESN'T END
THERE.
THIS PAST WEEKEND ALONE 73
PEOPLE WERE SHOT AND TEN WERE
KILLED IN THE WINDY CITY DESPITE
THIS OUT OF CONTROL VIOLENCE,
DEMOCRAT CORY BUSH IS DOUBLING
DOWN ON HER CALL TO DEFUND
POLICE.
>> YOU SAID YOU HAVE YOUR OWN
SECURITY, WELL ALMOST IN THE
SAME BREATH ADVOCATING FOR
DEFUNDING POLICE.
>> THE REASON WHY WE HAVE THESE
PROBLEMS IS BECAUSE THOSE THAT
WERE IN POWER AND COULD HAVE
FIXED THIS PROBLEM BEFORE NOW
DIDN'T AND IT COST LIVES.
WE'RE ADDING MORE MONEY TO THE
POLICE, BUT WE'RE STILL DYING.
>> CONGRESSWOMAN --
>> YOU KNOW KATIE, WE JUST GOT
DONE TALKING ABOUT TWO CLASSES
OF IN THIS COUNTRY, ELITE.
CORY BUSH'S POSITION SEEMS TO BE
THAT SHE IS MORE IMPORTANT THAN
EVERYONE ELSE.
HER POSITION DOESN'T SEEM TO BE
JUST LET THEM EAT CAKE, IT'S LET
THEM EAT LEAD.
>> ABSOLUTELY.
OFFICER ALLEY FRENCH ONE TO MAKE
A DIFFERENCE IN HER COMMUNITY
SIGNED UP FOR A DANGEROUS JOB IN
ONE OF THE MOST DANGEROUS CITIES
IN THE ENTIRE WORLD AND WOKE UP
THAT DAY TO DO HER JOB TO TRY
AND HELP AND SHE GOT A CALL THAT
ENDED HER LIFE AND THERE ARE
DOZENS OF OTHER OFFICERS AROUND
THE COUNTRY WHO HAVE SUFFERED
THEIR OWN FATE AND YOU HAVE THE
MAYOR MAKING STATEMENTS AND
PEOPLE LIKE CORY BUSH WHO HAVE
IMPLEMENTED THIS LEFTIST
IDEOLOGY AT THE MAYOR LEVEL, AT
THE PROSECUTION LEVEL AND
CRIMINALS ARE IN CHARGE AND IT
DOESN'T SEEM LIKE THEY'RE DOING
ANYTHING TO MAKE SURE THAT THIS
DOESN'T KEEP HAPPENING.
AND, YOU KNOW, CORI BUSH KEEPS
ARGUING SHE WANTS MORE SOCIAL
WORKERS TO BE INVOLVED.
WELL, CALL A SOCIAL WORKER TO
DEAL WITH A DANGEROUS SITUATION
WHERE SOMEONE WILL RESPOND TO A
TRAFFIC STOP WITH LETHAL FORCE
AND THERE ARE POLICE OFFICERS
EVERY DAY WHO GET UP TO SERVE
THEIR COMMUNITIES TO MAKE A
DIFFERENCE.
THEY DON'T GO HOME.
THEY HAVE FAMILIES, TOO.
AND IF YOU WANT TO REALLY
UNDERSTAND HOW THIS ALL WENT
DOWN, LISTEN TO THE POLICE
SCANNER BECAUSE THAT WILL GIVE
YOU A WHOLE DIFFERENT
PERSPECTIVE ON THE THIS ENTIRE
DEBATE.
>> DANA?
>> TIFFS GOING TO MENTION TO
CORI BUSH'S POINT IF YOU FOLLOW
HER LOGIC TO THE EXTENT THERE IS
ANY, ROUTINE TRAFFIC STOPS
SHOULD END.
WHY DO YOU HAVE ROUTINE TRAFFIC
STOPS BECAUSE THERE WAS A CALL
AND IT SAYS THIS COULD BE A
PROBLEM.
TURNS OUT ACTUALLY THE FEDS JUST
ARRESTED RIGHT BEFORE WE CAME ON
AIR A STRAW GUN PURCHASER.
SO SOMEBODY BOUGHT THE GUN FOR
THE GOY, NOW THAT GUY'S IN
TROUBLE AS WELL.
AND HER BROTHER, THE OFFICER'S
BROTHER SAID, HE IS AN IRAQ WAR
VETERAN SO THE FAMILY WAS ALL
ABOUT PUBLIC SERVICE, AND HE'S
DEVASTATED HE SAID GOD TOOK THE
WRONG KID IS WHAT HE SAID HERE
AND I THOUGHT THAT THE POLICE
SUPERINTENDENT THERE, HE SAID NO
ONE'S GOING TO MARCH OR PROTEST
FOR HER.
>> YEAH.
>> AND THAT'S A SHAME.
I DON'T KNOW -- I'M NOT
SUGGESTING PEOPLE PROTEST AND
MARCH IN THE STREET OR RIOT.
I'M NOT SUGGESTING THAT BUT HE
MAKES A REALLY GOOD POINT ON
WHERE WE PUT OUR VALUES.
>> YOU KNOW, JESSICA, MAYOR LORI
LIGHTFOOT WANTS TO MOVE THIS
AWAY FROM BEING A POLITICAL
ISSUE, AT LEAST THE DEFUND THE
POLICE POLITICAL ISSUE.
SHE WANTS TO ACTUALLY FOCUS IN
ON A DIFFERENT POLITICAL ISSUE.
LET'S WATCH WHAT SHE HAD TO SAY
AND I'LL GET YOUR RESPONSE.
>> THE POLICE ARE NOT OUR
ENEMIES.
THEY'RE HUMANS, JUST AS WE ARE:
FLAWED, JUST AS WE ARE.
WE HAVE A COMMON ENEMY.
IT'S THE GUNS AND THE GANGS.
>> SEE, JESSICA THIS IS A STORY
ABOUT GUNS.
IT IS A POLITICAL ISSUE.
BUT NOT DEFUND THE POLICE, GUN
CONTROL.
>> IT'S ALL THE SAME.
I WISH PEOPLE -- IT TAKES TOO
LONG UNFORTUNATELY, WE HAVE AN
HOUR SHOW WHICH IS A HUGE
PRIVILEGE TO REVISIT TOP INNINGS
AND GET PEOPLE'S OPINIONS ON
THEM AND UNFORTUNATELY THAT'S
NOT HOW THE NEWS WORKS AND
THERE'S SO MANY TRAGIC ANGLES TO
THIS AND YES GUNS ARE PART OF
THE PROBLEM AND SOMEONE WHO SOLD
A GUN TO SOMEONE WHO HAD A
FELONY CHARGE BEFOREHAND AND
THAT PERSON'S GOING TO BE IN
TROUBLE AS WELL.
IT'S A PROBLEM THAT THESE GUNS
USED IN THESE CITIES COME FROM
CONSERVATIVE STATES WITH LOOSER
LAWS AND THEN THEY GET BUFFED
ACROSS THE BORDER AND USED IN
CHICAGO.
SO I DON'T WANT TO BE LIKE OH
SILVER LINING IN THIS BECAUSE
IT'S A TRAGEDY TO LOSE A LIFE.
I'M HAPPY TO HEAR MORE NEW
ANSWER IN THESE DISCUSSIONS FROM
PEOPLE IN POSITIONS OF POWER WHO
ARE MOVING AWAY FROM JUST
STRAIGHT UP LIKE THIS IS ABOUT
COPS THAT GUNNED DOWN UNARMED
PEOPLE THAT WE NEED TO CELEBRATE
THOSE IN LAW ENFORCEMENT WHO DO
RISK THEIR LIVES EVERY DAY AND
WE ALSO NEED TO TALK ABOUT THE
VICTIMS, THE UNARMED VICTIMS,
BUT THE POLICE OFFICERS, IN THE
WAY THEY SHOULD BE AND THAT'S
SOMETHING ERIC ADAMS WHO WILL GO
ON TO BE THE MAYOR OF NEW YORK
CITY WILL DO VERY WELL.
WHERE HE NAMES THE OFFICERS WHO
HAVE BEEN SHOT AND GUNNED DOWN
THEMSELVES AND VICTIMS AS WELL.
>> GREG, NOT EVER STORY IS A
MEDIA CRITICISM STORY BUT TO
JESSICA'S POINT, IN 2019, THERE
WERE 14 UNARMED BLACK MEN KILLED
BY POLICE.
IN THAT SAME YEAR, 51 OFFICERS
KILLED IN THE LINE OF DUTY.
>> RIGHT.
>> I DON'T THINK AMERICANS
UNDERSTAND THAT CONTEXT IN FACT
I KNOW YOU DON'T.
IF YOU ASK PEOPLE HOW MANY
UNARMED BLACK PEOPLE ARE KILLED
EVERY YEAR, THEY GET IT WILDLY
WRONG REGARDLESS OF POLITICAL
AFFILIATION.
>> YEAH.
EVERY TIME THERE WERE RIOTS OR
DEMONSTRATIONS AND ARSON, WHAT
PREDATED IT?
IT WAS A VIDEO OF A TRAGIC, UGLY
EVENT INVOLVING EITHER THE DEATH
OF AN UNARMED SUSPECT -- LIKE
THE MEDIA, IF THEY WANTED TO,
THEY COULD SPEND TWO HOURS EVERY
DAY AND LOOK AT EACH CASE THAT
HAPPENS THROUGH THE YEAR,
BECAUSE THERE'S NOT A LOT.
LIKE IF YOU ADD BLACK AND WHITE
IN, I GUESS, OTHER, OR
NON-WHITE, IT'S PROBABLY ABOUT
TWO DOZEN, 30 MAYBE?
AND THAT WAS 2019 FROM THE
WASHINGTON POST DATA.
SO I WOULD SUGGEST THAT LIKE,
YEAH, PEOPLE SHOULD GET IN OTHER
PEOPLE'S FACES.
IT'S TIME.
IT'S LIKE IF YOU -- IF THE
MEDIA -- IF WE HAD VIDEO OF THE
DEATH OF THIS POLICE OFFICER AND
WE PLAYED IT AS MUCH AS THE
GEORGE FLOYD VIDEO, WHAT WOULD
HAPPEN?
WE WILL NEVER KNOW.
BECAUSE THAT WILL NEVER HAPPEN.
WE WILL NEVER TREAT THE DEATH OF
A POLICE OFFICER AS IMPORTANTLY
AS WE WOULD IN ANY OTHER CASE.
I UNDERSTAND IT, BECAUSE YOU
COULD SAY WELL, ONE IS AN
AUTHORITY AND ONE ISN'T AND ONE
IS ARMED AND ONE -- I GET IT.
BUT IF YOU LOOK AT EVERY SINGLE
ONE OF THESE CASES, THEY ARE SO
NUANCED AND I START TO SAY THIS
IS A REALLY HARD JOB, WE
DEMONIZED AN ENTIRE FORCE WHICH
THEN LED TO OBVIOUSLY THE
DEFUNDING BUT ALSO THE FERGUSON
EFFECT IN THE DRAMATIC RISE IN
CRIME.
MEANWHILE AND I SAY THIS ALL THE
TIME, LORI LIGHTFOOT IS
DEPENDING ON WHAT SHE'S CALLING
ON THE NATIONAL PROBLEM OF GUN
VIOLENCE.
THAT'S TO PAPER OVER THE FACT
THAT THE NATIONAL PROBLEM IS
CRIME.
RIGHT?
WHENEVER THEY TALK ABOUT CRIME
THEY GO THAT'S A LOCAL PROBLEM,
BUT THE GUNS ARE A NATIONAL
PROBLEM.
NO, NO,